well Kirsten the school district is also
busy helping with kovat 19 testing now
we can tell you that for schools and
East Las Vegas plan to welcome patients
this month who want a nasal swab 8 news
now reporter Kristen Drummond tells us
the goal is to reach the Hispanic
community
Eddie Ramos visits Courtney junior high
school I think it's a great opportunity
a location allowing him and others to
get a covered 19 tests this weekend
doesn't really hurt and it's very very
essential because we can stop the spread
doing this doing it this way wanting to
lead by example following concerns about
the virus impacting the Hispanic
community right now a lot of people
doesn't really think that it affects
them as of yesterday we had 20,000 622
positive cases in Clark County and more
than one quarter of those 5,000 883
cases were Latino cases to address the
matter for new testing events will take
place this month in East Las Vegas at
Clark County middle schools a
partnership among community leaders to
raise awareness and offer accessibility
we are a huge part of the community
these children these families they
attend school at our schools these are
people that they're part of the larger
school community no appointment is
required
it's a first-come first-served basis but
testing is limited 400 testing kits will
be available on each day of testing the
events continue the eye stunt with
smanos efforts a campaign launched last
week to share resources among the
Hispanic community but the reality is
we're all in the foxhole together right
now this is no time to have silos where
the school district is one thing and the
kind of this other thing we're all let's
work together working together to ensure
all have access to testing Kristen
Drummond 8 News now so they're making it
pretty easy there is no appointment
necessary at these testing events and no
one will be asked about a patient's
citizenship status now for the dates the
times and the locations there's a lot of
information there so we put it on our
website for you at 8 News now.com